high-tech editors Jimmy and Michael here
and we're going to show you how to build
a computer using a PC building simulator
so just just let you know this is in
almost like pre-alpha state and we're
gonna cut it we're gonna kind of walk
you through what is accurate but yeah
let's go ahead and jump into it hop
right into that okay welcome yeah you're
gonna want to pull up the help menu very
often because it's kind of confusing
what you mean okay well yeah that's your
inventory I think what is it there was
another key that kind of walks you
through what's going on so there's like
there's Q and T go on yeah II had to
toggle the help window so keep that in
mind okay um let's see don't press Q cuz
we got to stay in this tutorial don't
gotcha so I suppose escape yeah so okay
so we're looking at our case this looks
like I've actually seen this case before
this is a AdTech or something no it's a
coolermaster i want to say it's like
strikers unlike that but yeah that's the
case we go let's go waist handle at the
top um it's going around the room it's
here you get some like down sponsored uh
get open yeah yeah those are those ones
are there are actually backwards yeah
and then this looks like some sort of IT
room we got some boxes in the corner
this is WASD controllers in case you're
wondering yeah yeah
there's no physics on the boxes this
room looks so depressing yo call boxes
and stuff yeah hold hold
it's like an apple yeah Apple Computer
here like that mechanical yeah those are
those old-school keyboards so let's go
ahead and go back to the computer yeah
so that's actually trying to build this
thing out yeah so get started navigate
miscellaneous right-hand okay let's
stand offs stand on some spacers okay so
get in your inventory go to
miscellaneous all the way at the bottom
miscellaneous so the standoffs
in case you're wondering if you've never
built a PC before this is what you need
to insert into your case before you can
install your motherboard
some of the premium cases will actually
it pre-installed yeah this is where we
gotta put the standoffs all right
brother so so here we're just simply
dropping them in yeah clicking yeah but
in real life you would want to screw
these in with a some sort of screw tool
but this is one of the first steps in
building a computer yeah so okay it's
like power supply yeah this is also
going to tell you their build order
which can vary but we'll just roll with
the build order that they're giving us
here so so far not so bad I mean that's
one of the first things you should do is
yeah and I'll just it's all stained
house and okay so power supply all right
looks like there's only one right now
Thermaltake it's a 500 watt power supply
yeah in this tutorial we're given one
type of product for each part okay now
we're gonna install IO shield that is
good under miscellaneous all right also
just the note when you you don't just
drop a power supply into the computer
yeah screw in the back part right there
so usually there's like four screws in
the back here that you'll screw in and
then hold it in place
yep I am so right now the IO shield
that's a good thing to install it's one
of the first things you kind of want to
do that before the motherboard so
miscellaneous assume yeah slap that baby
in yeah okay inventory press alright so
we're gonna do the motherboard now
you're gonna have to be careful with the
IO shield because sometimes it is kind
of sharp and yeah there's like yeah
edges to it that can actually cut you
yeah when you when you actually install
the IO shield it's like you gotta like
won't Jam that thing in there because
then it snaps into place there's nothing
to screw it just like has to snap into
place oh yeah and there's one kind of
weird thing about the power supply
there's no cable where the girls at yeah
there's no cable so normally like right
here is where the cables would extend
out and then there's like some cable
management holes here yeah why are the
cables through and they connect it to
the motherboard with the screw holes
here looks like we're gonna put a full
ATX extended ATX motherboard it's a full
cell tower
yuria yeah so let's go ahead and drop my
motherboard in so a seuss motherboard
looks like yeah when I actually don't
know exactly what motherboard this is
might be an old model of sorts so yeah
actually that's out in real life yeah so
they kind of I just like in this game I
just kind of plopped it in
you do want to do that obviously and
then have them go over the standoffs
that we install they're going to
protrude out of the motherboard a little
bit and then from there you what you
want to like screw them down I don't
think that they've incorporated that
step yet well first off you wouldn't
necessarily build this vertically you
probably want to lay it down I like to
lay it down myself it is possible to do
something up good luck though so at this
point you would wear the standoffs are
you would screw the motherboard into
that so it actually holds a place but it
seems like it has been done yeah that's
a part that they thank you emitted all
right so I assume we're going to do a
drop cpu now is it kind of up to us
assume okay yeah that's gonna solve CPU
so I actually like to prep the
motherboard first I mean everybody does
it differently I like to you know put
the CPU on the motherboard and the RAM
onto the motherboard beforehand so on
the case but everybody does it
differently and that's fine it's not a
is that right it wrong yeah there's no
there's an odd way there's always way
that's it's kind of actually this is
probably closer to how I would build a
computer yeah so you gotta gotta take
that hook out and then you latch they
kind of glossed over that that's a nice
little animation but it kind of glossed
over you actually yeah there's like a
little lever they have to press down on
it Isis okay now to install the CPU okay
go ahead select the CPU pretty
straightforward um oh what is it already
in there oh okay so one thing that's um
that I want to note here is that you
have to be very careful with its own CPU
there's only one correct way to put it
in and the way that you know how to do
it is that there's an arrow
unlike the usually on the bottom left or
so and it aligns with the socket this is
your socket yeah because the socket only
fits the CPU only fits into the socket
one way and you have to pay attention to
the CPU itself where it has that arrow
in the corner match it with what it
shows on the socket itself and it should
it should just like lay there perfectly
like just yeah there's nothing to push
it out I'd right in screwing it which is
to drop right in yeah
so once you got that down the next the
next part is you want to clamp down on
the thing and that that makes a lot of
people nervous but you do have to apply
a pretty decent amount of pressure yeah
actually right around here then you have
to get back to you right here sorry and
it gets a little bit uncomfortable okay
so now it looks like they're doing
thermal
paste so that you know keeps your cpu
from overheating what's going on here
the that I closed that way yeah yeah I
write that clothes boy all right so now
we're gonna go to this animation again
we're gonna go through our inventory
okay at their own pace so I think again
this is where people kind of differ on
on how they build I like to put a piece
shaped um you know piece of glob in the
middle some people like to kind of
spread it around you don't want to put
too much yeah when once you press down
once you install the CPU core it's gonna
apply the pressure yeah for you already
all right so it looks like CPU core is
what's next in this tutorial I'm just
gonna go ahead and do that it looks like
this they want us to install a air
cooler which is actually easier than in
water coolers yeah water cooling is a
whole nother game it's not it's not
super let's see if they have that's not
super hard but it's just cool just
different yeah stop cool ooh all right
we're gonna go ahead and add all that
one in I guess they're going over the
GPU now cuz it makes em well to to make
note here installing CPU coolers a
little bit more complicated yeah so
let's go ahead and talk you walk you
through that a little bit so this is a
stock intel cpu cooler very common and
you just drop it in and then there's
like these four corners here you kind of
have to push in and like turn clockwise
and I like to install it in a sort of a
star pattern so if you're gonna go right
you know with the top right one first
then you want to go to bottom left and
then go down this way and yeah because
you want to make sure you're applying
the pressure you should when you're when
you're screwing it down it's just like
with anything like when you install your
tires onto your car you want to go in a
star pattern and apply even even
pressure across across the board so yeah
and also you're gonna have to plug that
CPU fan into one of the slots there in
the motherboard which they don't show
you it might actually be that that you
see that white you can't really crouch
in this thing or I can't boom in I don't
know um but we can walk through the
motherboard afterwards and it and kind
of point out some things so right now
they're actually advising us to install
the video card
I generally install the RAM before I get
to the D card video card is more like
the last things I install just my
personal preference but let's go ahead
and and do it their way
inventory encoder graphics cards looks
like a sheet exe 680 couple generation
couple years old yeah what's all good
yeah 1080p can kind of do that that's it
that's all there is a song that's all
there's a song yeah that's a very quick
um promise if you can install second we
do SLI and okay so we're gonna do SLI
oh there you go um there's a couple
things here that I should point out
that's not quite accurate so if you're
gonna do SLI you're gonna SLI bridge
yeah there's over like between here yeah
there's no SLI bridge in your inventory
so you would have that second video card
sitting in there and when really be
doing anything yeah um that's way for
the video course to kind of sync up
otherwise it won't work and then also
there's like screws here that you would
normally clamp down right there's like a
PCIe like switch thing that you want to
press down on so you can insert the card
yeah so it will snap back into place
once you have my to apply pressure yeah
so when you when you actually install
your video card you're gonna when you
slip it into the PCI Express slot if we
got that nice click right right there
and then you also like you mentioned
screw it into the case so it doesn't
wobble it doesn't like hang yeah damage
your yes a PCB these video cards that
say cards like like these video cards
are actually heavy but they can get very
heavy and they're held up by the PCIe
slot here and then they're held up by
the screws like typically two screws for
each video card if you don't install the
screws then they can actually warp and
Bend your motherboard you don't want
that happening as I can get pretty heavy
or will Bend the PCB on the on the video
card
yeah and in case you've never installed
a Delta computer before you want the
HDMI ports and all that stuff -
obviously face on the outside in case
you're wondering how to orient them and
I think that's you know that's that's
pretty dummy tip but you know trying to
incorporate everybody into this right
right and okay I think the next thing
was the red asses to do the ramp so he
can either RAM slots over them oh so
looks like we actually there actually
has to actually press down yeah hey
that's that's cool that's kinda cool
yeah you got a you know push those open
before you before you can even stick
their RAM sticks in there okay now it
looks like they're asking a standstill
the memory which is just the random
access memory
the RAM as it is known all right we're
gonna go into memory so ddr3 this is
older platforms so most RAM nowadays is
DDR 54 okay we're gonna go with the four
RAM sticks here yeah let's max that
alright so one thing I want to point out
in regards to installing Ram is again
like the CPU there's a correct way to do
it as correct orientation and you kind
of want to just you can kind of eyeball
it and see there's going to be like two
different
I don't what do you slot the slot has
two sections and one is obviously longer
than the other so you can look at the
RAM stick itself and like orient it yeah
with the slot so it's not it's not hard
to figure out but just don't be trying
to jam that if it doesn't look it don't
don't force it but actually well once
you do get into the right spot you do
want to force it so when you install Ram
you want to force it down and those
those little pins that we opened up
earlier those will close into the RAM
stick itself automatically once you've
applied the correct pressure so now
they're asking us to install the hard
drive or hard disk drive HDD SD : hey I
got no SSDs man y'all living in the past
do yeah so a point of contention that
I've seen in my articles I absolutely
recommend an SSD I would not recommend a
friend to build computer without
necesitar this purpose which is gonna
install hard drive which a well if you
look at the top right corner we had 2000
bucks an hour oh and I it's bet I would
recommend y'all spend some good I can
get an empty a really good computer with
$2,000 by the way can get a really good
computer for under like under $800 but
for now we're gonna be working with this
uh hard disk drive storage okay yeah
there's no more of the options oh wow
okay um so let's go ahead and talk about
installing the hard drive right right
right
and I think okay we can install four
that's cool lots of storage one thing
that we really didn't mention with in
regards to the video card now that I
realize it and the hard drive is you're
gonna have to install cables so if you
look closely I think that this is like a
video card with like 8 plus 6 pin power
connector so you're going to need a
probably going to need to beef your
power supply than 500 Watts yeah all in
thing like this yeah it is really I mean
they didn't
to install for hard drives and to video
cards but uh I probably recommend
getting a little bit more than 500 watt
okay let's see um fan system fan I got
fans man cool is it simple fan looks
like we can do three I don't know young
simple fans uh okay the last part is
cabling is okay so now now that they're
highlighted green means those are all
the things that need to be cabled or
both connected to the power supply uh
yeah
so right now you to advance you would
want to go to cabling mode okay okay oh
then it asks you what cable you're
supposed to connect which is sort of
like a quiz I feel like a quiz yeah yeah
it's like a quiz yeah so this is going
to be twenty twenty four pins let's go
and take a look at it yeah so it kind of
explained I try to kind of explain
what's what we're plugging in so we've
kind of we've plugged in all the
components now we just need a wire
everything up and get everything powered
right so this is going to be depending
on your motherboard you might have a 20
or 24 pin usually my 20 pin you might
find on like a smaller like Mini ITX
motherboard like a very small on the
board this is probably gonna be 24 pin
so that is just the power of the system
the motherboard basically so we're going
to go ahead and choose 20 24 pin yep and
then let's go on to the video cards here
yeah so the video card is going to the
eight pin PCIe
yeah at least for that side of the video
card press escape okay okay so that was
the eight pin and as I mentioned earlier
this is an eight pin plus six pin so
this is actually kind of a beefy video
card needs a lot of tower gonna require
a lot of power
yeah so that's this is going to be a 6
pin the reason you know it's eight pin
or six pin is if you actually look at it
in real life you don't already get on it
so I assume this is going to be the 8th
one yeah and then it's kind of
obstructed oh is it okay it's all good
and here man you don't know we're going
to go out of force anything spin here
cool and that is all powered ready to go
so the video cards transfer data to the
computer via the PCI Express get some
power that way to 75 watts and then
additional power some video cards
actually won't even require on this at
all and then so this is all the video
cards all ready to go and then let's see
we got without that mess alive
though I think it's a supplemental CPU
yeah because usually on a motherboard
it's it just says CPU power yeah okay
and then I think these are some fans I
want to say oh those are fan connectors
um fan cable maybe that's for the the
CPU fan already we didn't connect it yes
yeah so they have the CPU it is plugged
into the motherboard like physically
plug in but it actually needs to
communicate with the motherboard this is
what that cable does you have this one
for this fan back here the RAM connects
via the RAM slots the CPUs in the socket
so that's how transfers information and
I try to think of what else are we done
I need the the hard drive so you can
spin the the case around Oh back out a
little bit okay yeah see those buttons
on there on the wall oh okay yeah this
is a weird like a lazy susan kind of
thing yeah swing in a row this is nice
like she is yeah the the case connectors
like for the USB ports and like the
power button those are not included in
this model that we're looking at but
they will be there and it will probably
be wired through the back of the case so
you're actually going to need two sets
of cables for the hard drives you're
going to need power and you're gonna
need one for data and then I'm guessing
let's see how we do it do I just click
on it uh yeah click on again you wanna
pick the right cuz of this we're gonna
set a now remove SATA for the data trend
let's see so the smaller one is gonna be
the data so let's go ahead and do that
yeah I assume yep it's kind of a product
in both of these like when you're
installing it in real life they're
l-shaped so there's only one correct way
to plug these cables in we don't have to
worry about that here but when you do
actually build a computer you will and
then the other end of the cable is going
to be the same that just goes into the
motherboard and then now that's the data
we're gonna do the power so that's just
going to be set up our yeah and then
just a couple more of those whoops from
SATA power get I goofed at done Boop
okay that's a lot of date of May
Congrats there's a couple things so what
what is going on here
did we not put this do we not put the
front it got worried about right on or
the side things if you go into the
inventory
okay case however there's a DVD oh yeah
we can stop can we install DDR did I let
me okay I'm gonna move it a little bit a
little bit more comfy so Oh golly do I
hit f1 again so we are gonna load this
is very weird in real life there are no
mount modes mentally you gotta be yes
hold on bro I got again to mount mode
real quick I need to get out of unmount
mode yeah okay so then I go back to
inventory do DVD not so uh you might
letting me unless don't need diesel DVDs
no more uh okay yeah normally you'd I
mean it's fine to build a computer
without optical drive now
um and then yeah you want to kind of put
the front I don't even know what you
call it the grates or whatever back on
here because this nobody wants to look
like this and sometimes you can actually
have case fans in the front for a good
airflow I like to have you know it's
like neutral air Plus you have some hair
up like second a fan second in fan here
and then you have the back blowing out
hot blowing out here something like that
you can also do a kind of a heat rises
kind of thing as well that generally
covers the gist of building a computer
yeah I don't think they're like out of
the big things that you need to do with
building a computer the front panel
front panel connectors they didn't
really talk about which oh right kind of
a pain in the butt and that would
generally be like down in this area
tucked behind the video cards yeah oh
yeah you mentioned you can't crouch you
can't really see yeah I can't work out I
don't think there's a bunch maybe in the
maybe the final version yeah but yeah
keep in mind that this is a yeah with
crouch mode up do you gotta enter gotta
enter crouch mode exit now but keep in
mind that this is a pre-alpha so this is
a unfinished product but it is really
nice to see what this has to offer right
now and where it could go anything that
we mentioned that is missing from the
actual building process may be
implemented in future updates for this
thing I had fun playing this and
hopefully we can go back and revisit
this game when it's actually finished or
near near completion
[Music]